This is a setup. I don't like
that. What was that? His debut.
He's never fought before.
So having a fight in a
smaller organization or
not just feed them to these
fucking, he shouldn't be initiating
pencil. He shouldn't be in jeans.
It's not disrespectful to him and
it's not disrespectful to the sport,
but it's disrespectful to a large scale
organization to have a guy who's a guy
who's coming in from pro wrestling. He's
got a big fan base. Do it the right way,
and then eventually make your
way into a bigger organization.
What are you talking about? He's like
homemade event on ESPN. The how'd that go?
How'd that work? Awful. We watch it
together was a joke. It was a jet. Well,
I knew that guy was, uh, was fading quick.
We were talking about it in your
green room. I was like, he's fading.
I don't like to wait,
stepping. He looks exhausted.
He tired out quick and then he hit
that too. With the illegal knee.
Do you think he's still going
to be in the UFC after that?
100% they've invested too much in them.
Dana said he's going to have another
fight. Wow. Interesting interest.
It's a bummer. But that's the life we
live. And what do you do with them?
What I do with them dances and God
wouldn't have his learning here, Derek.
I did give him Derek Lewis and give him
the fuck out of there. Go. He like women.
Here's Derrick Lewis who came
from a domestic violence home.
He's pretty good enjoying
this. Oh, you want to be a
fighter? Here's Derrick Lewis,
Derek, Derek. But there [inaudible].
I know he has some added.
How many fights is Greg hardy had was as,
that'd be his fourth.
He had three on the f whatever,
getting white. So with a guy like that,
it was a pro bowler. Really Athletic.
Wouldn't his learning curve be very,
very steep. But what are quick
wouldn't he wouldn't. He is too much.
There's too much. There's too much
to download. Especially at his age.
He's 30 so that you've got to
download a lot of information.
So maybe he's working a lot on striking,
but you can't cover Jiu Jitsu,
kickboxing, wrestling, bottom. Not all
you are, no matter who you are. No,
it doesn't matter.
You Take Herschel Walker,
it doesn't matter if they're that great
of an athlete takes a fucking while to
learn the skill.
Well,
Herschel Walker was world class
athlete and a lifelong martial artists.
Different animals. Yeah, different. Yeah,
but I'm saying even if you take an
athletic like Lebron James would struggle,
did you throw them to the UFC?
I firmly believe that Hershel Walker
would have given a lot of dudes a hard
fucking time at his age or if you started
in his forties even as forward as I
think he was such a fucking
freak stud of an athlete.
He's such an outlier who would
have given a lot of that speed.
He had a 35 he's running, he was running
Olympic speed, which was in the Olympics.
He was such a freak.
She's such unbelievable and a real
martial artists like really had skills.
Like when, when I first saw
him fight the UFC, I was like,
or it strike force rather. I was like,
oh my God. Like he can actually fight.
Like dudes are scared of him. Like he
was, he was moving in the right way.
He wasn't doing anything wrong.
Who's taken guys down, smashing them.
And the physical power that he had was
just scared body. So stupid. Ridiculous.
So the team, he trained with Ak q's
ready. He did it, went to the right place,
and they gave him the right fights. It
was good. Yeah. But if you start younger,
you dove real prominent. Yeah, no problem.